I've been at Google for almost a year
now and one of the my favorite things
about about working here is the
availability of people who have like
real in-depth knowledge of how the
browser works and like a lot of the
assumptions I had as a developer just
didn't hold true and they were able to
show me why so it's great to bring that
to to a wider audience so over the first
talk today please give a warm welcome to
Greg Greg Simon and Erich Segal yes
thank you huh perfect all right terrific
I'm going Simon I work on the blink team
here at chrome and i'm erik seidel also
work on the blink team um so when Eric
and I were coming up with a plan of what
we're going to talk about today we tried
to put ourselves in their shoes that
what would we you know what would we
like to hear from the people working on
the actual browser engine what do you
have you know what what's it coming new
the next six months that's that I can
use and what have you been doing since
you forked you know WebKit and so that's
basically the structure of our talk
today we have three sections yep yeah
push this button here and doesn't work
how do we get there how do we get here
meaning what happened since we forked
WebKit and what we're going to be doing
you know what this isn't working that
great and how can I best influence
because at the end of the day the folks
that work on blanket chromium really
work for you guys right we publish a new
developer API basically every six weeks
because that's what Chrome's you know
shipping schedule is so we're going to
start by having Eric he's a gun going to
talk a bit about what we've done since
before and we're actually really were
really fortunate to have eric i'm here
today he's worked on on the source code
base for lying about eight years right
so like that longest of it of anyone on
the chrome team so yeah so blank blank
very exciting or at least very exciting
for us as Greg mentioned we've been here
about eight months April fourth was our
big d day we were WebKit or part of the
web community and we forked to have
blink a separate oh
source project first thing we did is we
deleted half our source code half which
we didn't necessarily need and then
we've spent a lot of time taking our
tangled integration with chrome and
trying to make it look a little bit more
like this we're still maybe not done but
what I want to talk about first is non
code changes to blink but rather process
changes because I think this is the part
that is most affects the people in this
room in this room and on the live stream
this is the part that's maybe most
observable to those who don't hack on
the blink code base so one big change
that we main is we add an intense system
we wanted to make sure that our decision
making process for what we change about
the web platform is an open process and
one that you can participate in so every
time before we're going to change the
web platform we send a public
announcement to blink dev announcing our
intent to add a feature or to remove a
feature then we've often we coat it and
then the very next day after it's
checked in it's already there shipping
in our canary builds it's off by default
but you can turn it on using about flags
experimental feature we get feedback
from you during that process we get
feedback from our own internal testing
or testing in the open source project
and then the second email that's sent
again to our public mailing list is an
intent to ship and this is where we
evaluate is this feature far enough down
the standards process do web devs like
it because again the feature that we
implemented behind that flag is the
exact feature that has specified by the
spec no prefix is no nothing and then
once it's approved by the community to
say we can commit to this indefinitely
then it appears in chrome so even if
you're not following on our mailing list
we try to make it very easy for you to
be informed as to our feature
development process you go to Chrome
status com you can see the features that
we worked on the features that we've
shipped the features that we're planning
to deprecate and even if you're not
paying attention to that we announce all
feature changes on the chromium releases
block I with links to bugs which you can
get to the tracker dashboard which you
can get to to the original discussions
on the mailing list I actually forgot to
mention on the tracker dashboard
you can edit this this we try to track
not just chrome changes but also the
status of these features in other
browsers and if you have information
about that you can request edit access n
change yourself so another big policy
change which affects again particularly
web developers is that this WebKit
prefix that we had in the WebKit world
we're trying to remove from blink and
additionally we have no plans to add a
blink vendor prefix we think this is a
good thing instead we implement fly we
implement features exactly as their
specified behind a runtime flag which
means that you can access them way
sooner than you use feel before when we
implement behind a compile-time flag so
to talk about other code changes that
we've made or so that was some process
bits let's talk about some code we've
removed lots of code as we mentioned in
the very first slide including a bunch
of broken WebKit features or features of
the web platform that we're added 20
years ago but never worked we have not
done this in the dark we have done this
using data from anonymously reported
aggregate statistics by chrome users who
opted in with the I wanna report my
anonymous usage data and this is again
all public you go to Chrome status calm
and you can see here we're tracking the
usage of CSS features across the web so
if you scroll down this list you'll see
ones that are used in 0.0001 percent of
websites and those are the ones that are
on the chopping block so yes so other
code changes one of the major focus that
you heard Linus talk about which you've
heard other talks talk about is that we
live in a multi-platform web and or a
multi-device web and it's important for
consistency across those devices
something we've not done super well at
up until now and so one of the focuses
of the last six months has been to try
and improve that story across versions
of Chrome and across now versions of
blank a big part of that was shipping
Android webview
but you can see we still have a lot of
work ahead of us this is a benchmark on
the web html5 test which shows that yeah
things are getting way better we're much
closer to desktop in terms of having one
set of web platform api is everywhere
but we're still not quite there so to
demo the at least getting better part
greg is going to give us a demo of one
of the new features that shipped in the
last Android then this is the so one of
the most requested features in chrome on
Android was the Web Audio API and we
finally we we finally working what it is
is it's a JavaScript API that lets you
assemble audio graphs with different
sort of audio processing nodes things
that you wouldn't normally write
JavaScript to actually run because
they're fairly performance sensitive and
so you can do very very cool things do
you see though yeah which is them it's
the camera there's a ok cool they're
alive so here I've got I'm just playing
a loop and as I drag my finger I'm
changing parameters on a bike lock
filter that is part of novio process I
can be managed either and again this is
it like very small amount of code but
you know these are things that people
like to do so here it is you couldn't do
it it's also really really useful for
games because you can actually play
sounds and in different parts of space
from so so we're making lots of changes
and as you saw we're removing lots of
code but one of the things we were asked
to talk about in this talk was a little
bit about how the sausage gets made what
happens besides the scenes and to I
guess reassure that we are trying to
make sure or working very hard to make
sure that we aren't breaking things as
we go so one of things we do
to keep the wheels on the wagon is a lot
of testing every single change we make
to blink is tested immediately by over
30,000 tests and that's just the blink
test not to mention all the chromium
tests that run additionally later and
you can see again all these are our
public you can see all our thousands of
bots you can see some of the tools that
we use to diagnose failures you don't
need that necessarily for for your
worlds but it's public in case you want
also we focus a lot on security there's
a link at the bottom you can click to
learn more but we have systems that
throw millions and millions of broken
web pages at our engine to make sure it
doesn't fall over and sometimes when I
make a change that to one part of the
web platform that interacts badly with
another part of the web platform that
you didn't necessarily expect we this
sort of system catches it an hour later
it's kind of amazing we do the same kind
of things with speed we have thousands
and thousands of benchmarks that we run
on every change and we have a 24-hour
sheriffing of these bots in these graphs
that alert us when we regress speed and
then they have a little button here we
can click to bisect and find out exactly
which change caused that speed
regression very powerful technology yeah
this was this was something that we
realized last year we had way too many
graphs that we couldn't have humans
track them anymore so we used some
signal processing that was available
from inside google it's actually to
actually not only detect when things get
slower but when things get faster doing
so we have like you know you know perf
increase of the week you know email like
it's attempted said right it's very cool
very much of focus of ours we're also
not just trying to not get slower we're
also focused on getting faster one of
the things that this same team produced
for us in the last couple months is they
ran a million websites on desktop
through the browser and and took
aggregate statistics and they also did
the top 25 k on mobile mobile
significantly slower so it takes a lot
of hours and mobile and what you can see
on this is this graph is actually really
very depressing to me because the blue
when the orange is you and the
is us getting in your way and that's a
problem something we're very aware of
and actively working on fixing and the
graphs have actually gotten a little bit
better since then we've started to tick
away at the low-hanging fruit but we
have a long way to go so Greg is going
to talk about what else is coming down
the pipeline cool thanks Eric so
whatever so what new API is what new
performance parts are you going to see
in the next six months well first of all
a biggie is is is is web components so
this is something that Eric bidelman
covered pretty well and is talking about
polymer we've been working on this for
almost three years of course nearly
every JavaScript you know UI framework
has it has its own component model
because that's sort of what you know you
know boilerplate for doing you eyes and
it means that you have to buy and
totally to one framework you can it's
very it's for its it's very tricky to
mix and match them so we decided three
years ago to work on building this
functionality into the platform to make
UI frameworks much more lightweight and
and also fix some of the you know
namespacing problems you know what you
have so there are three parts there's
the shadow Dom where you can encapsulate
Dom so it can't be walked through or
seen etc we've actually been shipping
this for using the video player works
with this this is even prior to us for
King Blanc we have we have custom
elements where you can actually create
your own your own tags so that your code
looks much more readable and we also
have HTML imports which which aids with
pulling in you know blocks of content or
in a you know pulling in actual
components you know so this is this is
coming soon we we have a last call on
custom elements for this month and the
other two we're working hard to click on
to get the specs you know in a shape
where we effete where we feel where we
we feel that we can said we can ship it
but you don't have to wait for that you
can start using it today because we've
written polyfills for
every evergreen browser that implements
all three of these things so you know
when chrome actually turns it on things
will just get faster if you if you ship
today web animation so for you I these
days having silky smooth complex
movement is now table stakes right you
know thanks yeah and so you can't you
know so we you know realize this and so
we've been working for the past six
months on on a new animation back in
that's going to replace the one that
drives SVG and and also the one that
front of CSS and we're also going to be
exposing a new API called the web
animations API now what's cool about
this API is it is timeline based and it
actually so here you know we have a new
animation object here but you can also
group them together so you can actually
create fairly complex animations that
are that are all synchronized so let me
show you an example of how that works
turn on the tablet here unlock it ok
cool so here is a simple animation here
because you can see I'm running on a
table here so I've got this is actually
much smoother than that the problem is
it doesn't seem you know to capture you
know well here I you know I have a few
curves here and you know ease in Enys
out and now of course we don't have the
native implementation of web web
animations shipped yet I think it sort
of runs but it certainly isn't shipping
this is all done with the web
enumerations polyfill the same team in
blink that is working on shipping web
animations and writing the new back end
they started by doing a polyfill and
that's what polymer uses them as well
another example of web animations here
where so here I've got two separate e2
to two separate animations and they're
going to run on the same timeline
so they're perfectly in sync when you
use the web when when you use this API
you you will always be getting the GPU
as well so very cool stuff so that's
going to ship some that's going two
ships sometime next year but as as I
said before you don't have to wait to
use it you can grab the polyfill and and
start using it immediately partial
layout one of the wonderful things about
the web is that it does lay out for you
you just throw text added right it's the
only platform where we're in hello world
is actually just the text hello world of
course this is also one of the problems
with a web is that it's doing layout
when you don't really want it to like
you just want to reach into the DOM and
measure where one div is placed and what
you know what happens is the clicker
doesn't work what happens is we we lay
out the entire page and so what should
have been a you know sub-millisecond
call ended up taking 25 milliseconds and
I just missed a frame all right so we
have changed blink so it now does
partial layout meaning it will only lay
out enough of the page to return the
value that you're asking for from and
then it will carefully unwind itself now
this hat but now even though we Dennis
already we haven't shifted yet because
we've got two we have two other problems
that were that we're dealing with one is
on chrome on Android we do double
layouts because we have to do text auto
sizing and then on desktop we're working
on getting overflow scroll bars it
turned on because the presence of a
scrollbar causes you to do extra layouts
anyway speaking of text tektite of
textile sizing anyone who's loaded a
page a destination of browser and the
page author hasn't set meta viewport
we'll we'll see this sort of behavior
where we basically lay out the whole
page we try to identify what the main
body of content is we set a minimum on
on thought sighs and then we lay it out
again now the algorithm could certainly
be could certainly be improved as you
can see by this
we've got this is this this is hacker
news talking about the Moto G i believe
and all this text should be the same
size but it's not so we are working on
that as i speak here today but we're
also going to do it in a single pass you
know as i mentioned when talking about
partial layout we can't quite ship
partial out until we can actually until
until until we only have two until we're
we're able to do just one pass so this
is coming very very very soon CSS grid
twenty years ago I worked on the web
browser for the apple newton 21 years
ago and one of our futures was tables
and it took a lot of code right tables
because and i'm still talking about
tables and it's 20 years later like what
it's time for some some some improvement
in this area so CSS grid was a feature
that was first shipped by internet
explorer we have it pretty much fully
implemented at least i say pretty much
because the spec is doing is is in last
call but it's still kind of being pushed
around a bit you know you can turn it on
and try it out but we expect to ship
this very very soon what's cool about
CSS Greta course is you can separate the
content from how from how it appears so
if you combine this with with media
queries you can do really really great
responsive design speaking of responsive
images this is something that you guys
want something that we want but we don't
have it yet and that's because there
hasn't been agreement on what the API
looks like there's been many patches
landed inside blink but of course you
know they haven't shipped yet but
there's some disagreement about which it
whether it should be picture source sets
or said I think it's not going to be
sourcing now I think it's now source
that or like picture to see it changes
almost daily I mean I did these slides
last week and I and
had to add the picture tag in yesterday
because that was the latest news you
know I know I know you you may think it
would be great if we if we just put our
foot down is just shift something and
but but then we're not then we're
forking the web platform right i mean we
really need to have you know the success
of the web is that it's consistent so
it's important that we take our time and
get at least one of the browser to agree
and show you know ideally we get every
browser to do it as well this is also
sub-pixel fonts the fonts on windows
don't look that great they can certainly
be improved a year ago we ship the
change in WebKit actually a year and
half ago which was we changed the
rendering the rendering precision of the
entire tree to be fixed point prior to
that it was a mixture of int and float
if you put a breakpoint in there or just
like boss the program and looked at the
call stack was a float float implode and
of course things worse you know off x 1
pixel you know constantly we got that
fixed the last thing to fix those fonts
of course you know looking at the column
on the coma the column on the left this
looks like you know a web page from 1998
when the only fought that you were
drawing was Ariel because it was in C
windows folder and I didn't do anything
because my cpu wasn't that powerful etc
the column on the right is what's going
to be coming very soon i think this
quarter and so you're gonna have not
only sub-pixel sizing but sub-pixel
positioning as well you know most web
content these days is is consumed on LCD
screens so you can use cleartype or even
you know increasingly you know retina
displays so this is important now it's
kind of hard on this overhead so you see
the difference it's very subtle look
whoa what I just do I'm printing it who
puts a print button off on a on a
presentation remote at the seam doesn't
seem that good
that seems like a fail yeah there it is
okay cool all right that's we'll look at
this II hear its Mutsy on on the left
it's much more genki very very subtle
right so this is direct right this was
actually a big change skia which is the
graphic system inside inside inside
blank I guess that blink uses to you
know to be correct it used GDI which is
the really which is a really really old
I'm graphics API on on win32 and you
have to use GDI in order to ship on
windows XP but starting with vista i
believe they turned on director right so
this is coming very very very soon in a
canary you know near you this was a
slide provided by our friends at v8v
it's not part of blank but it's an
extremely you know important piece of
chrome and a really important piece of
your life as well this p team is they
are they are maniacs about speed I mean
which is great and they will always be
meetings about speed because that's one
in the you know that's that's you know
that's what's called v8 and not in v6 or
like I for something right but coming in
the next six months we're going to be
bringing we're going to be improving
some of the es6 support things like
symbols and iterators soon etc and also
something called object observe I'm not
sure if Eric bidelman covered this
yesterday but a couple years ago in
blink we shipped Dom mutations where you
can set up a call back so so you know
when part of the Dom has changed so
object observe is a new new new equi
script feature that is the same thing
but for JavaScript objects so given any
arbitrary given any arbitrary object you
can watch when properties on a change so
you so if you put put two and two to two
together you've now got data binding
natively in the platform and it's fast
right because it's really tricky to
polyfill object
we do do it in polymer but it's not the
nicest piece of food I've ever seen okay
cool so how can you influence these
features and things that we work on you
actually can yeah as Greg said you know
you guys are king as history has proven
many times a platform is nothing without
his apps and you guys write the apps so
we want to know what you have to say if
you feel C++ in your blood and want to
write C++ with us all of our code is is
open you don't even have to tell anybody
you can just simply change it you rather
you don't have to evangelize to us you
can just simply post a batch all of our
code is open our bug tracker is open one
of the critical Pat step or one of the
path only one of the steps on the
critical path to anything getting
changed in blank at least anything web
facing is a bug so whether you file that
bugger we file that bug again you guys
know what it should look like probably
better than we do and you have access to
our bug tracker you can see we're
working on you can influence what we're
working on another way that internal web
devs to Google at least help us to
improve is through reducing test cases
often a bug will come in and you know we
don't necessarily understand your
complicated web app and so helping us to
understand explaining it to us like like
we're five as it says on the slide is an
important step because every change that
we make needs a test and so whether you
write that test when we write the test
it has to be written longer term is the
question of standards as Greg mentioned
part of the beauty of the web is that
it's ubiquitous that it works more or
less the same everywhere you try and the
way we accomplish that is through
standards so they're always looking for
folks like yourselves who understand the
web platform to help standards bodies to
determine what the next web platform
should look like if we're moving too
slow or standards are moving too slow
you can always fix it yourself in
JavaScript to some extent and that's one
of the techniques that has become bigger
as we mentioned earlier in the slide for
us to sort of test out new features for
you to test out new features just to
simply write it in Jas
and finally if you guys do nothing else
we simply want to hear from you that's
why we're here today that's why we're
talking to the live stream is that you
guys again are in charge of the apps and
we want to know what you have to think
so you can listen in join into our
conversations on blink tab you can talk
to a son plus you can talk to us on
Twitter but we want to hear from you
yeah and we will be around I guess an
hour from now or so and you know we
would really like to hear you know are
we working on the right stuff should we
be prioritizing you know something
different you know cetera it's you know
it really matters to us so okay thank
you